(music)
Rui Cheng:
When Triple 8 first started in 2004, we had fewer than 20 dancers, but this year we have 47 dancers,
so Triple 8 has really grown as a group, and we've grown in so many other ways as well.
Rui Cheng:
So this year's show theme is "Phases."
It's a theme that centers around the idea of change and progression, of things that are constantly
Rui Cheng:
in flux in our lives. Our show will feature pieces in which day turns into night, water
will battle fire, and a couple will experience the passage of time.
Rui Cheng:
Our theme, "Phases," is more than just a sum of our pieces. The theme represents the changing
nature of our company itself, and it's also a tribute to those who helped our dance company
Rui Cheng:
grow into the group we are today. We hope you'll join us in experiencing phases.
(music)